what your sleeping position says about
you
[Music]
this is the most common position in the
world people who sleep in the field
position tend towards worry and anxiety
it's not all bad though I mean what
would this world be like without the
scheie sensitive types
[Music]
this position could lead to snoring and
a rough night's sleep if you have a
starfish sleeper as a best friend you're
in luck they're great listeners and a
source of comfort to others
sleeping like a soldier can lead to a
bad night's sleep try using a pillow to
support the natural curve of your back
soldier sleepers do not like to make a
big deal out of things they have a
strong silent type
this is a good position to avoid snoring
the urine our sleepers look like they're
grasping for something it's all part of
their long periods of indecision
but once they make a choice they stick
to it
this position can aid in digestion but
their sleep is unsteady they like to be
in control of everything around their
life they're outgoing and confident
people but for them extreme situations
that's a no-no
[Music]
for those who suffer from back pain the
log position could be helpful for you
log sleepers are very trusting a little
naive but are usually social and
easygoing individuals
[Music]
we trains
[Music]